[Music]
much of civilizations most profound
wisdom actually lies in the past some of
the most important the Lusaka teachings
are thousands of years old
we in modernity need to be less
hubristic in believing that we have all
of the answers in the industrialized
world we need to identify these most
fundamental spiritual teachings of the
past and bring them into a union with
modernity making us more aware of our
interconnectedness with nature and each
other one of these beautiful ancient
teachings is understanding Asha and blue
way it can be thought of as a yin and
yang of action versus inaction
[Music]
asha comes from the Yoruba people in
Nigeria it's the power to make things
happen and produce change like this
simple act of planting a seed
[Music]
whoo where can be thought of as inaction
not forcing with deep roots in
Confucianism and Daoism think about this
as having a perfect economy of energy by
not acting you actually gain more
control of the situation
so we're going to balance between acting
and not acting let's give some very
simple examples when someone finishes
speaking you have an arsenal of
possibilities yet like clockwork we
almost always choose to react with our
perspective of logic emotion a question
this can be viewed as a chef embodying
the power to make a change
much less we choose whoo-whah in action
in which we'd reply with a nonverbal
head nod stay completely silent or even
exit the conversation how about when we
feel hunger arise should we take action
and go eat or should we stay focused on
what we're doing and not act on that
hunger should I take the action of
exercising right now or should I not
take that action
it's a critical perception system
because we would not have some of the
greatest achievements in the world if it
wasn't for a chef if Michelangelo did
not summon the power to make things
happen we want to have the Sistine
Chapel or the Statue of David
if Elon Musk didn't have a chef we won't
have SpaceX
or Tesla now again that can be
juxtaposed and balanced with whoo we're
in action where almost everyone is
forcing their perspective into left
versus right politics in the US or
geopolitics abroad by just staying
silent and observing other people by not
forcing your perspective in you can
actually gain more control of human
affairs when people see your meditative
in action not indicating if you agree
disagree not blurting out your
perspective or critique of other people
they eventually realize how this can
lead to better discourse and less
stressful conversation this is one of
many ancient philosophical teachings we
must grasp and embed into our future
the balance between unleashing a power
within us to produce change versus not
forcing the beautiful Asha and woowoo
the yin and yang of action versus in
action